Hello, hello, hello.
Thank you so much everyone for coming to the show.
Everyone looks so good.
If you're like, "Is she staring at me?"
The answer is yes.
(audience laugh)
We have a really big show for you today.
A whole lot of show, we're celebrating the Super Bowl!
(audience cheer and clap)
And we are talking football, cram and snacks,
and yes, pet and puppies.
And then we have a rocom love fest
with an all-star cast from the new film,
"I want you back".
And then we're talking about love gone wrong with the women
from the shocking new documentary,
"The Tinder swindler".
They're here, I know.
And we're gonna hear their story.
This is the one everybody's been talking about.
They're gonna give us all the details
and maybe things that you can't get from the documentary.
So I'm very excited about this.
But first, I like to hit the headlines.
I like to find out what's happening in the world.
So let's get some good news!
(audience cheer and clap)
All right, it's time for Drew's news,
your tasty news weenies wrapped in good news blanket.
And with me at the desk is the co-captain
of our news team, Rossy Ross Mathews.
That's right, hey everybody.
Hi.
Hi
Rossy?
Yeah.
You're a big football fan?
You know I am.
So I grew up watching football.
The only way I could communicate
with my brother and dad was watching Seahawks games.
And now it's like this lifelong love affair.
I am so ready for the big game this Sunday.
Are you guys gonna watch?
(audience cheer and clap)
I cannot wait
because It's all about just gathering around with people.
Everybody's watching it.
It's like a shared experience we're all doing together.
That being said, let's turn to some people
who are really the aficionados and authorities,
two incredible sports geniuses,
host of the podcasts "Naked with Cari Champion".
Please welcome Cari Champion.
Hi Cari.
(audience cheer and clap)
And contributing Writer for "The Atlantic"
and host of "Jemele Hill is Unbothered",
the one and only Jemele Hill.
Hello.
(audience cheer and clap)
All right, now this is a historic Super Bowl.
It's first ever in SoFi Stadium in Englewood, California
and only the second time in NFL history
that a team gets to play on their home turf.
So tell us, do the Rams have the advantage here?
Well, I'm gonna say I'm from LA, so I am Rams die hard.
Anything LA, I'm going with Rams, but if I'm honest
if I'm just being honest with both of you guys
and Ross you know this, the Bengals have something special.
And dare I say that I'm leaning towards in my mind,
I think they may win,
but I'm rooting for the Rams wholly.
I'm hitting my bets right now.
Jemele, thoughts, feelings, all of it?
Okay well, first of all,
let me just warn you guys, I'm pained.
And so, as you see behind me,
this is the San Francisco 49ers helmet
because I am a 49ers fan.
So I hate the Rams
'cause they're in our division.
We lost to them in the NFC championship.
I was there to witness this in person.
So because I value my soul,
I'm not rooting for the Rams.
They're devils to me.
See, I love that.
Yes, that's football to me.
You gotta be brutal.
Good Jemele, that's the Moxy I want,
that's the kinda Moxy I relate to.
But I think I'm feeling the Bengals.
I'm just gonna say it.
(audience cheer and clap)
And I love Los Angeles.
I'm gonna be in so much trouble
and I will be so happy if they win.
But welcome back to LA and being the second team
in history last year, Tampa with the Bucks
and now Rams in SoFi,
there's just so much good stuff to talk about.
And it's why I'm picking the Rams by the way to win.
I just have to say, I'm picking the Rams.
Well, thank God, thank God!
Oh, you wanna make a friendly bet?
Yes!
(audience cheer and clap)
Drew, if your prediction comes through
that the Bengals win,
I will eat a whole bowl of macaroni and cheese,
which she tries to force feed me on the regular.
You have no idea how big that is for him.
And if the Rams win, my prediction comes right,
you have to watch an entire episode of "90 Day Fiance".
All right, done.
Wait, neither one of these sound like punishment.
I don't know.
Macaroni and cheese is amazing
and so is "90 Day Fiance".
It sounds like a good time.
Yeah, I might have to macaroni and cheese
while I watch "90 Day Fiance" and same, same.
(upbeat music)